- Here's my thing, y'all.
Season two, Bridgerton, I
was like, "go ahead and try."
(laughing)
It was so good, did you like it?
If you let me down right now.
If you let me.
- Don't think of us differently.
We haven't had a chance to watch it yet,
but we're gonna watch it together.
- I know.
- She's gonna kick us off the show.
(applause)
(laughs)
- Oh Kelly!
- What, you literally just
won an album for this thing!
No, wait, or what an album?
Won a Grammy for this thing!
Wait, you, I'm so jealous.
It's like you, you know, haven't
seen Sixth Sense yet know?
- I know, I know, we're so excited.
- I just watched that for
the first time, by the way.
- Isn't it tripping?
- And I didn't know, I didn't know it.
- Exactly.
You don't know.
And then you're like.
(mimes head exploding)
- Have you seen Pretty Woman?
- No.
- What?
- I've seen bits and pieces
of it, like on the TV,
but I've never watched
it all the way through.
- Really, what about Rocky?
- Yes.
- You have?
- A classic.
No, let's get back to season two, ladies.